and we have a guest with christian
thank you yasser we are here with a
newcomer into the u.s seniors
championship vladimir kopian welcome to
st louis welcome uh to our show how does
it feel to be playing here in st louis
very well i'm very happy to play here
and in general it's a very good
opportunity of course for
players over 50 like like me
and
i would like to
thank of course everybody here
who made this possible and especially of
course uh rex stinkfield for this
opportunity now take us a little bit
through your tournament after this point
you started off with the white pieces
you got a winning position out of the
opening in that one but unfortunately
weren't able to convert
how did you deal with that loss
yeah by now i'm just i'm losing uh very
good opportunities not not only the
first one of course was very striking
but
also in my game with guriwich i missed
yesterday also it was a very good
position
uh okay what to do yeah as a chess
player i mean i'm used to this so it's
normal losing uh
winning position winning lost positions
uh yeah of course it's somehow very
painful when you uh get this but
actually i can't
i can tell you what happened i i had to
play of course on this on the 39th move
of course being b5 it was much simpler
but somehow i felt about the z5 move
that this is wrong
because this was uh
such a move bishop on d5 was
standing there and now e5 so i somehow i
figured out that queen a7 should be
right move the only of course the thing
is that you should of course um
calculate the 40s move at this point
40th movies
yeah but what i did i i just i did not
see at all the queen d7 move but somehow
i saw knight f5 and i thought okay after
knight f5 at least i keep a draw so
there is draw after 95 only to discover
after uh rook f7 of course is the move
that i will calculating and my intention
was to play queen a6 of course not queen
f2 and this is what i had to do and it's
still it's uh
yeah it's still a game it's
i mean it's it's probably draw i mean
it's impossible to hold but the point
was after rook b7 my calculation was 97
check
and then i have this draw everywhere
only to discover already after 40th move
that king f7 and when calculated i had
calculated queen g6 king take c7
committee g7 and just completely forgot
about bishop
yeah and and somehow i discovered this
and at this point i you know i was very
disappointed i thought that this just
lost position yeah anymore would lose i
even saw after when i say ruby son b3 c
takes b3 but for some reason c3 only
calculated not c4 and okay i decided
that okay i just i miscalculated i'm
just losing so queen f2 i thought okay i
had to do something or resign
immediately yeah and this is what
happened actually but after that one you
did bounce back with a victory against
shabalov in round three and now finally
with another big victory with the white
pieces take us uh through today's game
actually uh yeah today's game um i mean
i i analyzed this line uh of course
queen takes d5 and bishop c4 is mainline
i analyzed this uh some time ago and i
um conclude
my conclusion was that uh somewhere in
the endgame why it was much better but i
just could not remember
i mean i of course i did not expect this
today this line and i just couldn't
remember and if you you are not
remembering this you you can't afford
going into this line right with my king
somewhere on e2 or d1
and i tried to remember but i just
failed and then i decided okay probably
no advantage but i can't say that yeah i
just play safe probably nothing i mean i
believe black is just in total control i
mean any move uh
i mean i don't know d4 should be played
or not it's possible i believe without
d4 after d4 say
knight h4 queen f6 was strange i thought
just bishop takes d3 and queen d5 next i
believe it's it's also normal like i
don't this is actually what the engine
was also recommending bishop takes d3
and uh potentially queen d5 try to take
it uh yeah that's where d5
centralization i mean i i don't know if
something but it's probably it's
probably just black black is a
normal position i thought maybe queen f3
i have to play but okay this just but he
played this move queen to f6 and this
allowed you to uh take yeah this should
be better for white but somehow i
believe i was not playing well and i
just i was i mean i have everywhere some
some additional opportunities many of
them and i always i was choosing
something bad i believe
uh
yeah this this i calculate something
my main my main calculations were like
rook e4 for some reason but then 97 95
93 quickly i did not like these
again maybe some were miscalculated but
king g2 another move that i was
calculating here but king due to g5
somehow i did not like
uh and then i decided okay maybe queen
e2 i just keep this position i don't
allow rook e8 maybe queen g2 at some
point so that i think that's a very safe
and uh precise move in fact uh g5 maybe
would have been a bit more decisive but
queenie two
maintains a priest yeah here again i
didn't know i mean i beat xa4 probably
possible i just i i was
i don't know i mean
this is also possible and then a5 i
secure this uh winning end game
everywhere
but then okay this before i mean i don't
spoil my position yet but somewhere
around here i i started spawning i
believe this all i mean h4 b5 very
unfortunate i believe i think h4 was
fine as well
yeah but b5 b5 is different i'm
g5 rook e6 uh
here somewhere i don't know sounds
something happens here i don't know if
this is
all right or not it's still more or less
all right yeah you're still winning
completely winning
yeah here somewhere already winning but
since b5 i did not like i mean i was
just cursing myself or this b5 move a3
is always hanging i mean any move would
do here i believe
g5 rook is six maybe simpler
especially already like approaching time
trouble playing something like b5
vera
i mean
this anti-positional move
but i just uh somehow i i i could not
actually understand what is going on
here and just
i think you're too much of a
perfectionist vladimir because this one
was pretty good as well um
and after that tell us what happened at
the end we were a bit confused because
let's go all the way until the end
and uh this is the position we saw on
yeah king g4 our broadcast okay okay
okay so we saw the position after b b
takes c6 rookie three and then a king on
e4 and we were like okay what happened
no no btx is a king g4 yeah this was uh
but you played king g4 first yes yeah i
played king g4 here after take c6 i can
play king g4
uh i mean black can take first bit xs
and then d3 but then maybe rook d2
something like this
and that's after b5 i'm still winning
yeah yes yes but probably spoiled
already something no no no not yet still
still very significant edge
congratulations uh vladimir guys any
questions no uh vladimir nice game if
anything uh the critical moment for me
was i was surprised by queen e2 which
doesn't spoil anything you have a very
big advantage but i was really surprised
you didn't go for the very forcing line
with g5 h takes g5 queen g4 because this
just looked like
you know you were just taking
a
complete um
control of uh the game if he takes on f4
beside rook e6 you can also play bishop
takes and it just
wow
very very very impressive yeah
definitely probably g5 should be played
i mean i was calculating this um
every move the g5 is possible but
somehow i thought just uh
i mean i was afraid to spoil everything
i thought that okay
as long as
white's position i mean positionally
very good
i should not spoil this so if community
2 keeps
some edge then i
this i mean my g5 possible but again i
was concentrating on this rook e4 mainly
king g2
and queen e2 move yeah queen f395
something uh so i was kind of g5
possible but again i don't know
i just probably yeah probably this is
right yeah this is like a decisive way
yeah to treat this position
congratulations uh you're fighting your
way back into the game after
this hiccup i want to say uh but uh
looking forward to the free day
yeah okay what to do
are you tired after five rounds vladimir
uh not put much pressure uh on you but
you were my pick to win the event so
keep it up
okay
thank you vladimir